[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 loisirs tout de suite le
sommaire la fête de la science revient
pour une 29e édition le thème de cette
année la relation entre l'homme et la
nature
à suivre le programme complet de la
commanderie et du réseau des
médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines découvrir les
artistes et les artisans d'art de
carrière sur scène ce week end au fil
dollars propose une balade culturelle et
touristique à travers la ville notre
journaliste justin brasier nous en
parlera sur ce plateau était en train
l'agenda complet de vos sorties du week
end
au programme un spectacle une balade et
du cinéma
explorez les sciences à travers la
biodiversité
cette année c'est le thème de la fête de
la science à saint quentin en yvelines
qui se déroulera jusqu'au 15 octobre
ce week end la commanderie à l encours
se transforme en village des sciences
le reportage de schiste in brazil un
village des sciences à la commanderie de
saint quentin en yvelines
un lieu qui n'a pas été choisie au
hasard il permet de mêler la discipline
à la culture tels que la danse ou les
arts visuels
objectif diffuser la connaissance
scientifique et technique en village des
sciences c'est une réunion en fait deux
partenaires différents partenaires
scientifiques et culturelles diverses
on peut avoir des associations on peut
avoir des scientifiques des artistes qui
du coup qu'ils vont proposer des stands
qui vont être qu'ils vont proposer
manipulation rencontre discussion jeu
autour de thématiques scientifiques
thématique cette année l'observation
scientifique et le rapport de l'homme à
la nature
au programme ateliers autour des
abeilles fabrication de mangeoires à
oiseaux plonger dans les serres de
laboratoire mais aussi danseur virtuel
et ateliers d'écriture avantages du
village des sciences et que ça regroupe
vraiment des thématiques des horizons
vraiment différent pas avoir vraiment on
a de l'astronomie juste à côté vous avez
de la botanique
vous avez d'une des associations
naturalistes des entomologistes vous
avez vraiment de tout et vous avez vous
avez aussi des ajustements avec la
commanderie vous avez aussi des
propositions culturelles et artistiques
si le public visé est familiale
l'événement est accessible à tous petits
grands amateurs ou experts les propos
sont vulgarisés il n'y a pas besoin
d'être d'être vraiment un astronomes
professionnels pour venir et commence à
découvrir des choses là vraiment c'est
c'est pour s'adapter à tout le monde
qu'on est con con et de grandes
connaissances scientifiques ou non et si
vous n'êtes pas vance ont fait irruption
il ya aussi j'attends des propositions
artistiques et culturelles qui sont
proposés l'événement se déroulera à la
commanderie les 10 et 11 octobre
programme et réservations sur le site
internet et les médiathèques aussi
participent à la fête de la science
elles ont choisi elles ont choisi de
s'attarder sur deux aspects
les petites bêtes du jardin et le
biomimétisme au programme des animations
des tables rondes des et beaucoup
d'ateliers pour enfants comme le samedi
10 octobre à la médiathèque du canal les
plus petits pourront écouter une
racontines une histoire pour les enfants
à 10h30 ou prendre par un atelier hôtel
à insectes à la médiathèque le phare
amoureux pas samedi à 10 heures
charlotte colin assistante de
conservation observé ce bibliobus nous
explique pourquoi il faut participer à
ces ateliers en fonction de ces
sensibilités en fonction de mon âge je
raconterai quelque chose nous qui nous
plaît et qui nous parle parce que parce
que aussi prendre du temps pour observer
la nature et tous ses super pouvoirs
parce que biomimétisme s'inspire des
super pouvoirs de la nature c'est aussi
commencent à réfléchir à comment on va
pouvoir relever les défis qui arrive
votre activité dans les yvelines pour la
fête de la science au port-marly avec
une conférence sur l'astronomie vendredi
9 octobre de 20h30 à 22h en présence de
jean eudes arlon astronome à
l'observatoire de paris
le thème l'astronomie dans la vie
quotidienne
[Musique]
et on reste dans les sciences et on va
parler des sciences de la terre la fête
de la nature revient ce week end à
carrières sous poissy elle se déroulera
au parc du peuple de l'herbe
samedi 10 octobre de 14h à 18h le thème
de cette édition de 2020 s'intitule
prenons en de la graine
interview express avec véronique
brondeau responsables du parc du peuple
de l'herbe en la fête de la nature donc
c'est un événement national donc qui est
porté par l'association fête de la
nature et l'objectif c'est de valoriser
donc l'environnement par des activités
que ce soit ateliers conférences balades
de faire en sorte voilà qu'on de de
profiter de la nature dans toutes ses
dents tous ces domaines il y aura des
activités dans le parc à proximité de la
maison des insectes donc avec atelier
avec la ligue pour la protection des
oiseaux sur le voyage des graines des
activités leur art avec l'association
ville verte
on aura aussi des randonnées familiales
qui seront proposés vous avez aussi la
maison des insectes qui sera ouverte
gratuitement donc où là vous pourrez
découvrir l'exposition permanente
d'insectes vivant donc dans des
vivariums l'après-midi avec l'office
pour les insectes et leur environnement
dans cette maison il y aura aussi des
courts documentaires sur sur les
insectes qui seront proposées une
exposition temporaire donc de l'artiste
johnny le bigot qu'on peut découvrir
derrière moi donc qui sera aussi
accessible au public et à partir de 17h
donc il y à un concert un duo le duo
narcisse qui a qui va venir se produire
pour participer à cet événement national
c'est aussi pour nous faire en sorte de
proposer des activités qui vont dans le
sens de préserver l'environnement
acquérir des connaissances sur sur la
nature pour mieux la préserver
au quotidien tout est fait pour
sensibiliser les le public de façon à ce
qu'ils comprennent l'importance de la
nature dans notre quotidien et les
gestes qu'il faut le faire qu'il faut
mettre en oeuvre pour la préserver cette
nature les artistes de carrière sur
scène vous ouvrent leurs ateliers pour
la deuxième édition du festival au fil
de l'art l'événement se déroulera ce
week-end le 10 et le 11 octobre de 14h à
19h pour en parler sur ce plateau
justin braz et bonsoir bonsoir en quoi
consiste l'événement est bien le
principe de l'événement en fait c'est de
provoquer une rencontre entre les
visiteurs et les artistes leur atelier
s'est fermé en fait toute l'année même
si bien sûr on peut l'ouvrir sur demande
mais là c'est vraiment l'occasion de
venir puisque en fait il y aura un oeuf
artistes et artisans d'art qui vont
ouvrir leurs portes tous en même temps
et sur place alors comment ça va se
passer bien sur place vous pourrez
échanger avec eux bien sûr découvrir
leurs créations et même les acheter
l'idée comme vous l'avez dit célia c'est
de présenter leur savoir faire
ils sont peintres photographes
céramistes ferronnier d'art
donc il y en a vraiment pour tous les
goûts et l'objectif c'est d'allier la
découverte artistique et la découverte
touristique parcours on peut faire à
pied ou à vélo dans le sens de carrière
en allant d'un monument à l'autre d'un
lieu sympathique du village et en
passant par tous les ateliers d'artistes
et d'artisans d'art donc le but si je
comprends bien c'est que les visiteurs
se baladent à travers le village
exactement oui alors ils le disent ce
n'est pas une porte ouverte c'est
vraiment un parcours culturel dans la
ville de carrières sur seine lors
atelier se trouve en fait dans le centre
ville et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'ils
ont eu l'idée de se regrouper entre
artistes le collectif a d'ailleurs
réalisé en fait un plan une petite carte
avec un itinéraire à suivre le plan est
disponible sur le site internet bien sûr
du festival
fils de l'art et sur leurs réseaux
sociaux on peut voir d'ailleurs le plan
qui s'affiche à l'écran
chaque atelier y représenter par un
numéro en orange ce sont les endroits
sympas de la ville à découvrir par
exemple la grange aux dîmes le moulin ou
encore un panorama sur la défense une
grange d'ivresse on a une mairie aussi
donc c'est vraiment il ya des choses à
voir
il ya des ruelles qui sont piétonnière
et qui sont donc il ya toute une
histoire il ya des plaques aussi à des
endroits différents
alors justin pourquoi ils ont décidé
d'allier la culture et le tourisme
l'objectif en fait c'est de donner de la
visibilité aux deux bien sûr aux
artistes mais aussi à la ville ils ont
décidé tout simplement de faire
découvrir à carrières-sur-seine des gens
des villes à côté ne connaissez pas
carrière chatou monter son ouïe saint
germain se connaissent pas en fait
carrière sur scène n'est pas un endroit
de passage
on est entre deux ponts sur la seine il
ya le pont de chatou et le pont de
besoin on est vraiment entre les deux
donc heureusement pour nous il n'y a pas
trop de passage mais du coup les gens ne
connaissent pas alors qu'il ya un très
joli chemin de halage il ya c'est
vraiment une ville qui est agréable à
découvrir un très beau parc
comme l'année dernière il y aura un jeu
qui s'adresse aux petits comme aux
grands
le principe est le suivant en fait aux
premiers ateliers que vous allez visiter
ils vous donneront une feuille avec des
questions et il y aura une réponse à
trouver dans chacun à des ateliers et un
tirage au sort sera effectué parmi les
bonnes réponses avec à la clé la
création d'un des artistes
merci beaucoup justin et puis on se
retrouve comme chaque semaine pour une
nouvelle chronique avec plaisir et si
vous préférez vous amuser autrement
d'autres activités sont prévues comme le
spectacle the rockies
samedi 10 octobre à 17 heures à la
maison de l'environnement à magny les
hameaux
ce groupe de rock reprend des titres
universel sur des instruments d'enfants
merci
[Musique]
autre événement l'établissement public
d'aménagement paris saclay propose une
balade à la découverte de la
biodiversité du campus urbain samedi 10
octobre à 11 heures
et puis enfin venez vous promener le
temps d'une marche pour découvrir le
circuit des peintres paysagistes dans la
vallée de chevreuse samedi 10 octobre de
14h à 17h cette sortie sera accompagnée
par une guide du parc naturel régional
que faut-il aller voir au cinéma comme
chaque semaine la parole est donnée aux
programmateurs des salles
saint-quentinoise et aujourd'hui c'est
gaël kino responsable du gip du grenier
à sel à trappes qui nous parle du film
les choses qu'on dit les choses qu'on
fait au micro de patrick jacq tedx net
[Musique]
au cinéma le grenier à sel nous vous
proposons les choses qu'on dit les
choses qu'on fait c'est un film qui fait
partie de la sélection officielle du
festival de cannes 2020 évidemment le
festival n'a pas eu lieu mais il ya
quand même ce label label festival donc
c'est un gage de qualité quand même
ce film est porté par des acteurs
épatants comme camélia jordana
vincent mccain emilie dequenne nice chez
nestlé d'air le réalisateur c'est
emmanuel mouret c'est un réalisateur
français que l'on suit nous au grenier à
sel depuis ses premiers films
il a notamment réalisé
mademoiselle de jonquière avec cécile de
france et edouard baer qui était sorti
fin 2018 emmanuel mouret sait il est
aussi connu il est surtout connu pour
ses comédies d'amour à la marivaux les
ce film là aujourd'hui c'est dans la
même veine puisqu'il s'agit d'un chassé
croisé amoureux avec des amendes et
maîtresses des trio amoureux des secrets
il ya donc des histoires légères et des
histoires plus grave mais au final
finissent par se condenser dans un seul
récit c'est un peu une fresque
sentimentale avec thé où les
combinaisons sentimentale se nouent et
se dénouent
moi je trouve que c'est un film
magnifiquement interprété qui a trouvé
sa place sur nos grands écrans et il a
aujourd'hui une très belle presse un
super bouche à oreille et c'est vraiment
tant mieux ça fait plaisir à voir
alors vous aussi vous pouvez venir le
voir dans notre salle au grenier à sel
[Musique]
et c'est la fin de ses études choisir
merci de nous avoir suivis
rendez vous la semaine prochaine pour de
nouvelles idées sorties même endroit un
honneur bonne soirée à jeudi prochain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]